here's the thing Nancy it's not easy
being a mommy mobile just ask Kate
Hudson today we are shooting all couture
Chanel Valentino barefoot in Dior Kate
covered in couture for the new in style
favorite look I loved the Jean Batista
floral the 36 year old getting personal
in the Mother's Day issue out next
Friday saying quote sometimes I feel
like a bad mom and an essay for a cover
story the single mother of two confesses
quote some days I find myself doing
strange things that don't have any real
purpose and faraway corners in my house
and I realize I am literally and
deliberately hiding for my children
ultimately her message was that there is
no such thing as perfect balance in
style editor kelana barfield brown on
Cates parenting confessions Kate said
that although she does homework with her
kids there are some times that she would
prefer to watch The Bachelor instead and
I think a lot of people can relate to
that okay do his worth the reported 38
million dollars has been busy promoting
her book pretty happy and tells us she's
been falling a little short in the
cooking Department luckily though she's
pals with Paltrow rider like has you
know dinner over there he comes back
he's like yeah I mom when it made this
like you know like roasted tomato and
melted mozzarella and but I'm like you
know what